if there's an epitome of the classic car
then it's this two-seater together with
the Chevrolet Corvette the 1955 Ford
Thunderbird is the American sports car
Manuela Feist is a fan of classic
American automobiles and especially her
55 t-bird she loves the way it looks but
she also appreciates its performance
the first generation t-birds had 200
horsepower by comparison Porsches built
at the time had only 70 me 16 mano a lo
says she's fascinated by the v8 American
cars of the 1950s because they have a
lot of displacement in power that gives
them their typical blum blum engine
sound so in his bloopin droppin this
just hot was man wheless interest in
automobiles is no coincidence her father
was a car dealer so she grew up on
Chrome and oil she says that even as a
little girl she played in and around
cars her father taught her how to drive
almost as soon as her feet could reach
the pedals she's always been a car
enthusiast she was born with gasoline in
her blood he also is MIT is practice
individually leaked one nearly
decapitated blew the t-bird was a hit
from the moment it appeared in showrooms
Marilyn Monroe road through the United
States in a Thunderbird on her honeymoon
the car remains popular because of its
clean styling as of 1958 the t-bird
became a four-seater and lost much of
its charm
even in goldenrod yellow the car doesn't
look overly ostentatious that's part of
its appeal
manuela says that people wave and
applaud when she drives by and adds that
vintage cars put people in a good mood
they like a bright yellow vintage car
that has lots of chrome and sounds good
she says she's never had a negative
experience in her thunderbird negative f
our own thing about the nineteen 55
t-bird was surprisingly affordable
aficionados call it the early bird and
they say it's the most attractive car of
the cars eleven generations it sizes
modest for a u.s. car of its era and it
fits in a standard European garage
people began collecting t-birds over 30
years ago and fans have always been able
to get spare parts if its mileage word
soap or 20 liters for 100 kilometers the
Roadster would still be considered a
relatively practical everyday car it's
technology is simple and reliable
manuela is even able to do some of the
repair work herself popsicle move inside
of it she says that in one case she
photographed the engine and then
enlarged the print one day when the
engine wouldn't run she compared it with
the photo she figured out what was wrong
with the engine and fixed it what up the
stunts a movie that if I heard the tbird
packs a muscular v8 engine under the
hood competing models from the time like
the jaguar xk 140 only had six cylinder
motors with 4.8 liters of displacement
the engine delivered around 200
horsepower to the 40 matic three-speed
automatic transmission other cars have
since bested the t-birds performance but
none has ever matched its sound
first generation t-birds are becoming
harder to find the technology was robust
but the exterior was prone to rust and
bad weather took its toll an early bird
that still in relatively good shape is
worth around 45 thousand euros